bien les clubs il y en a toujours existé
et 6 et des clubs pour réfléchir moi je
suis pour que la réflexion sur la plus
large possible et s'il arrive à étendre
notre propre stade influence sur notre
gauche dans notre droite
je prends si en revanche ces clubs ces
deux nouvelles écuries de nouveaux clans
et de nouvelles façons de nous fracturée
alors là je serai sans pitié sans pitié
sans pitié battant plusieurs fois exclu
du parti socialiste je ne laisserai pas
ce parti qui avaient déjà été fracturés
à de multiples reprises se fracturer à
nouveau le mandat qui m'a été confié par
les militants assez précisément celui là
c'est d'arriver à rassembler et réunir
cette famille moi ce que je veux croire
et dans les discussions que j'ai avec
les uns et les autres c'est plutôt
qu'ils ont envie maintenant de passer à
autre chose de concret terminée tout le
monde a compris et donc maintenant il
faut avancer ensemble
mais s'il y avait la volonté
effectivement de rejouer à l'infini ce
que nous avons connu les congrès de
rennes de reims aux femmes pouvaient
citer sous ces congrès qui ont été
épouvantables et ses 50 nous venons de
passer au cours desquelles personne ne
s'est sauvé en fait ni les frondeurs ni
les légitimistes
au bout du compte n'ont réussi à faire
entendre leur voix nous avons été
ensemble
disqualifié donc soit on pense que cette
disqualification n'est pas une bonne
leçon à retenir
et on continue soit on pense au
contraire que quand trop c'est trop on
arrête et bien moi je pense que trop
c'est trop
donc vous n'hésiterez pas à montrer vous
êtes aussi un homme d'autorité mais je
ne cherche pas être pareil si les
circonstances si sa constance m'appelait
à l'être je le serai évidemment mais je
ne souhaite pas je ne cherche pas à
montrer que mes petits muscles multibras
et s'efface en blanc je cherche pas à
dire que je suis le nouveau camp nou 14
je dis simplement que il ya un moment où
ce que me demande le mandat que j'ai
reçu de ce congrès d'accord
effectivement de faire en sorte que
soient respectés un collectif donc ne
pas fait tondre une ligne il ya des
vignes league et les nouveaux riches la
ligne la ligne est simple c'est le
respect d'une discipline collective
c'est à dire que on débat autant qu'il
est souhaitable mais une fois que le
débat a été tranché
il y a une parole qui est une parole
unique c'est à dire qu'il ya une voie
unique on peut écrire les choses
différemment avec sa sensibilité avec
les uns et les autres il n'y a pas un
seul champion mais il y a par contre un
seul message et un seul but vers lequel
on se dirige pour marquer